[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
mercredi 15 novembre voici le programme
de ce soir si aujourd'hui la voiture
électrique est directement menacée par
la forte hausse du coût des matières
premières l'entreprise etamet a
peut-être trouvé la solution et hier
avait lieu l'inauguration de son usine
de recyclage de batterie électrique à
trappe la ministre de la transition
énergétique agnè pan runaché s'est rendu
sur place réparé plutôt que racheté de
nombreux ivelinois ont franchi le pas à
Mor pas SOS accessoir le leader français
de
l'autoréparation a dû déménager dans de
plus grands locaux tellelement la
demande était forte mais comment
fonctionne-t-il on fait le point dans
cette émission un mot de football
également dans votre 78 pour le 7e tour
de la Coupe de France
ouille se prépare à affronter anger le
match s'annonce difficile les joueurs de
ouille évoluent en régional 1 alors que
les joueurs d'Angers sont en Ligue 2
interview avec le président du club
soutenir les femmes entrepreneuses c'est
l'objectif de l'association Femmes des
territoires elle vient d'ouvrir une
antenne à rambouiller nous en parlerons
avec Sandrine tarditti et thérèe mayali
ce sont nos invités du
78 voilà le programme de l'émission de
ce soir mais avant on va faire le point
sur les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Michel
midoro bonsoir bonsoir alors on commence
ses information en prenant la direction
de Versailles où un lycée a été évacué
aujourd'hui ce mercredi 15 novembre aux
alentours de 9h45 le lycée mariecury de
Versailles été évacué en raison d'une
alerte à la bombe l'établissement reçu
un message d'alerte et les respons ont
fait retentir la sonnerie pour évacuer
les lieux l'annexe du lycée a elle aussi
été évacué les forces de police et les
démineurs ont fouillé les locaux sans
rien trouver ces dernières semaines les
alertes à la bombe se multiplient dans
les îles vines que ce soit dans les
établissements scolaires ou les lieux
culturels comme le château de Versailles
et après versaill on va prendre la
direction de poissi des postes vont être
supprimés à stellentis oui Mathilde
l'usine située à poissi va réduire son
personnel le groupement Automobile
International décidé de supprimer une
équipe de travail sur son site pisaké
objectif mettre en place une nouvelle
organisation à partir du 28 novembre une
réorganisation qui fait suite à des
problèmes de logistique et
d'approvisionnement des fournisseurs
concernant la fabrication de l'Opel Moka
de la DS3 crossback au total 560
personnes sont concernées par cette
restructuration 200 à 250 intérimaires
ne seront pas conservés selon le groupe
stellantis la production ne baissera pas
et sera maintenue à 12000 voitures par
mois à Montini le bretonux vous l'avez
sûrement remarqué d'ailleurs si vous
êtes passé à côté du rond-point du
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
niveline l'arche de Piotre Kowalski est
en travaux construite en
1991 cette arche va connaître un beau
lifting avant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 depuis le 6 novembre les
verts bleus sont retiré petit à petit
objectif les nettoyer surtout les
ouvriers pourront remettre à œuf la
structure une fois terminé un nouvel
éclairage sera mise en service et le
bassin sera de nouveau rempli la fin des
travaux est prévue pour le printemps
2024 coût total de l'opération 520000 €
financé par la Région le Département
cant an Levin et la direction régionale
des affaires culturelles et enfin Michel
vous avez une dernière information
concernant la BGE Eveline le premier
réseau national d'appui aux
entrepreneurs lance un appel à
candidature pour la première promotion
de son incubatest après un entretien les
le candidat pour intégrer un parcours
immersif de 6 mois renouvelable lui
permettant notamment de mettre en place
sa stratégie commerciale et de monter en
compétence à la fin le dirigeant
récupérera son premier chiffre
d'affaires réalisé et continuera à
développer son entreprise si vous voulez
vous inscrire le site apparaît à l'écran
et bien merci beaucoup Michel el midoro
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78
news ce serait le défi du siècle sortir
des énergies fossiles c'est en tout cas
l'objectif du ministère de la transition
énergétique dans ce cadre la ministre
agè panier runaché a visité une nouvelle
usine à trrape son but tester le
recyclage des batteries des voitures
électriques pour réduire notre empreinte
carbone les explications de Régine
ralèche Clara de Frutos et Patrick
Jacques de dixmud le cobalt est dans la
phase organique il est devenu bleu al ça
va prendre un peu de temps à se séparer
comme comme l'uile et le vinaigre mais
c'est le même principe pour la la
séparation cobalt nickel ou lithium ce
sont les composants issus des batteries
de voiture électrique amené à être
recyclé et c'est ici dans ce centre de
recherche à trrappe que seront testé et
validé les premières étapes du recyclage
il y a une quarantaine de collaborateurs
qui vont travailler dans cette usine
pilote essentiellement des ingénieurs et
des techniciens nous allons en recruter
d'ailleurs de nouveau pour pouvoir
travailler dans cette cette usine pilote
et donc pour pouvoir tester ce procédé
qui sera après développé de façon
industrielle définitive dans une usine
àunkererc pour sa construction le site
de 800 m² a nécessité un investissement
de 10 millions d'euros dont deux de
subvention l'usine pilote représente un
projet phare pour le gouvernement qui
vise à long terme l'indépendance
énergétique l'enjeu c'est notre
planification écologique et la manière
dont nous allons développer des
solutions de mobilité électrique sur le
territoire des solutions qui soient à la
portée des Français et qui permettent
aussi de créer des emplois en France de
créer de la richesse en France et de
réindustrialiser euh notre pays l'usine
se donne 2 ans pour réaliser les tests
avant de lancer la phase industrielle à
dunerque et recycler réparer réutiliser
c'est aussi le cas à morpa la tendance
autour de l'autoréparation ne faiblit
pas SOS accessoires est spécialisé dans
la vente de pièces détach pour réparer
les appareils électrom ménagés il
connaît un tel succès qu'il a dû
déménager dans des locaux plus grands
c'est le reportage de réine de Régine
ralche ces entrepôts ce sont ceux d' SOS
accessoir le leader français de
l'autoréparation et de la vente de
pièces détachées avec une hausse de 30 à
50 % de la demande chaque année
l'entreprise a déménagé à morpa dans des
locaux de 8000 m car et a investi dans
un système automatisé pour la gestion de
leur
colis
mais comment ça marche première étape le
picking un opérateur prélève et
rassemble les articles d'une commande
dans un bac ce dernier est ensuite
déposé sur les tapis en direction des
tables de colisage les opérateurs
scannent et accolent une étiquette de
support du client et les redépôt sur les
tapis qui seront photographiés et pesés
par les
machines à cela s'ens su la formation et
la fermeture des colis redirigés grâce à
leur étiquette vers différentes gardes
et transport
ça nous permet de produire beaucoup plus
de colis de faire face à des grandes
variations de volume à produire ça
permet bien sûr aussi une meilleure
productivité dans certains cas une
meilleure qualité et puis un meilleur
confort de travail pour les opérateurs
depuis l'acquisition de cette machine
Olivier de montliveau l'assure aucun
licenciement n'a été effectué mais les
commandes ell ont explosé l'activité
peut atteindre jusqu'à 8000 expéditions
de colis par jour
38000 c'est le nombre d'emplois à
pourvoir en île-de-fance pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 700 offres
seront d'ailleurs à saisir à l'occasion
de l'événement les jeux recrutes qui se
tient au Vélodrome national de 5tin en
Yveline le 21 novembre Grégory canalé et
Clara deutos en parlent avec la
directrice du pôle emploi des Yveline
elle est leur invité dans ce soir dans
le premier numéro de sa recrute je vous
propose de regarder un
al vous parliez des 700 offres
disponibles pour cet événement les jeux
recrutent de quel type d'emploi
parle-t-on est-ce que ce sont des
emplois spécifiques aux Jeux Olympiques
qui vont s'étendre dans la durée et dans
quel secteur surtout alors c'est des
c'est à la fois bien sûr des offres qui
sont directement liées aux Jeux
olympiques mais sur des métiers dont on
a besoin tout le temps donc on va avoir
du transport on va avoir de la
logistique tout ce qui est on va avoir
aussi de l'événemenel
des des des métiers liés au médias aussi
on va avoir tout ce qui est dans la
restauration cuisinier
serveur on a vraiment on a aussi des
métiers dans dans l'informatique on a
tous les métiers de la sécurité donc le
spectre trs large de de l'agent de
sécurité au manager donc on a quand même
sur cet événement des métiers qui sont
en lien direct avec les événements qui
vont nous toucher directement sur le 78
via les Jos mais qui sont des métiers
sur lesquels il y a de l'emploi
maintenant et il y en aura évidemment
après puisque c'est des métiers qui
recrutent de toute façon et le premier
numéro de cette nouvelle émission sa
recrute est à retrouver ce soir en
intégralité sur tv78 juste après le 78
karting Laser Game buowling l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin en nielin
fêtait sa rentrée étudiante au speed
Park de Montini le Bretonneux les
étudiants se sont réunis autour de
différentes activités l'occasion unique
de se rencontrer et d'échanger c'est le
reportage de Clara de
Frutos au speed Park l'ambiance était à
l'unité pour fêter la rentrée étudiante
l'agglomération de saquenttin en éoline
organisait une rencontre entre les
différents établissements supérieurs le
9 novembre dernier au programme karting
Laser Game bowling billard ou encore
karaoké une occasion unique pour les
étudiants d'échanger et d'apprendre à
mieux se connaître on a organisé cet
événement parce que il est important
pour nous de faire rencontrer les
étudiants de 50 ans neline notamment il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de première année
2è année postbac qui sont présents
aujourd'hui et le but c'est de le faire
découvrir tous les services qui sont
dédiés aux étudiants qui appartiennent
donc à l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
une première pour 5 an iveline qui
semble avoir réussi son pari moi ça me
fait plaisir d'être là parce que j'ai
pas l'habitude de sortir forcément et je
trouve que que ce soit entouré par la
ville c'est plutôt sympa ouais ça fait
rencontrer du monde ouais c'était
vraiment super ça nous permet de
découvrir justement speed Park c'est
c'est une première pour moi je trouve ça
c'est bien parce que bah déjà on peut
passer une après-midi assez sympa entre
à midi surtout là en période de parcelle
ça nous fait un après-midi assez sympa
et puis on en avait jamais entendu enfin
moi j'avais jamais entendu parler de ce
parc avant donc ça m'a permis de
découvrir cet endroit donc c ass au
total près de 300 étudiants de 12
établissements supérieurs différents
était
présent un mot de sport à présent dans
votre 78 avec un match de football à ne
pas manquer ce weekend dans les
evvelines en Coupe de France ouille qui
évolue en Régionale 1 va affronter en
anger un club de Ligue 2 ce sera ce
samedi 18 novembre à 14h le président du
club revient sur cet événement au micro
de Michael
[Applaudissements]
elmidoro
avant le tirage proprement dit vous êtes
affecté un des groupes et déjà le hasard
a voulu qu'on tire comme le club de 2
labang les deux premiers de Ligue 2 donc
bon après vous avez quand même peu de
chance qu'il y a 14 matchs dans Group et
puis ça pas loupé c'est un gros j'avoue
qu'il y a 5 ans j'aurais voulu un gros
on av failli tomber PSG qu' on est tombé
rest une boule c'était celle du
parisgermain j'aurais voulu tomber sur
lance aussi que c'est V que lance venait
avec plusieurs milliers de supporters là
on avait vraiment rien anticiper
on va jouer le jeu à fond et croyez-moi
que le staff les joueurs sont motivés
mais en AUC cas on pourrait leur mettre
une pression de gagner absolument on est
réaliste en gestannée c'est très solide
ils ont fait arriver comme leader ça
s'est joué quelques secondes près à
pause soir ils sont 2è ils ont un projet
de remonter en Ligue 1 ils ont le budget
pour les joueurs pour donc franchement
c'est un très gros morceau donc hors de
question de mettre une pression qui
serait pas approprié au joueurs
staff alors les billets en tribune sont
à 15 € le portour 10 € et jeune 5 €
c'est ce qui se fait selon le calibre
l'adversaire il y a des clubs pour une
Lig 2 qui vont à 20 € mais on s'est dit
quand même qu'il faut que ça reste un
événement accessible à tous bon donc on
a on a tenu compte là encore notre
expérience passée et les différents
match qu'onganisé avec le variété et
cetera donc ça nous paraît des tarifs
abordables on a énormément de demande de
toute façon on fait de la prévente là
pendant 3 jours et puis les derniers
billets sont vendu le jour
même c'est bientôt l'heure de passer aux
invités du 78 mais avant je vous propose
de jeter un coup d'œil à la météo de
demain demain matin attention aux
averses dans les Yvelines prévoyez votre
parapluie côté température comptez 9°gr
à Versailles rouillé et oudans il fera
10°gr à montelajolie l'après-midi la
pluie devrait s'arrêter mais le ciel
serait sera toujours très couvert au
niveau des températures il fera 13 à
14°gr en moyenne sur le département et
le vent sera toujours très fort demain
après-midi attendez-vous à des rafales
de l'ordre de 60 km/h environ et demain
nous fêterons la Sainte Marguerite c'est
l'heure à présent de passer aux invités
du
et les invités du 78 ce soir ce sont
deux bénévoles de l'association Femmes
des territoires Sandrine tarditti et
Thérèse mayali bonsoir à toutes les deux
bonsoir bonsoir alors première question
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu l'association Femmes des
territoires en quelques mots alors
femmes des territoires est une
association destinée au femmes porteuses
de projet ou entrepreneur c'est un
réseau d'entraide de partage et de
solidarité et donc quels sont les
objectifs de se créer un réseau entreidé
c'est c'est ça c'est se créer un réseau
sortir de la solitude de
l'entrepreneuriat et apporter des
solutions des moyens pour aider au mieux
toutes ces femmes porteuses de projet et
chefs d'entreprise c'est aussi un moyen
d'encourager les femmes à entreprendre
Sandrine oui à entreprendre et aussi à
rompre cet isolement de l'entrepreneur
parce que bien souvent les femmes sont
seules à bord de leur entreprise et
c'est vrai que c'est important justement
de rompre cette solitude et ce réseau a
cette vocation justement de déjà nous
faire sortir de nos bureaux échanger
partager sur tout ce qu'on traverse en
fait nos victoires mais aussi nos
difficultés parfois donc le réseau nous
nous permet tout ça aujourd'hui les
femmes osent moins entreprendre que les
hommes les femmes ont moins la
possibilité d'entreprendre euh on sent
vraiment cette inégalité hommes-femme de
manière assez globale c'est un sujet qui
est assez assez fréquent et en
entreprise dans le salariat mais aussi
particulièrement dans
l'entrepreneuriat on voit que 42 % des
femmes sont porteuses de projet mais que
seul 30 % d'entre elles osent franchir
le cap euh de l'entrepreneuriat sachant
que pour la plus grande part de ces
entrepreneuses elles sont souvent en
association avec un homme 17 % d'entre
elles sont associés à un homme donc
d'ord c'est c'est assez déliquat c'est
compliqué toutes les deux vous êtes
aussi entrepreneuse et vous faites
partie de l'association Femmes des
territoires comment est-ce que vous avez
connu l'association et comment est-ce
que vous vous êtes dit bah je vais
l'intégrer h en fait donc moi j'ai
rejoint le réseau Femmes des territoires
en janvier 2023 donc mon entreprise date
de 2019 et justement je cherchais des
réseaux pour pouvoir partager et é
changer donc il y a beaucoup de réseaux
business qui existent et c'est vrai que
je me suis pas reconnu en fait dans ces
réseaux business et j'avais vraiment
besoin d'échanger sur le quotidien en
fait euh de l'entrepreneur et euh j'ai
aussi constaté que l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin et l'entrepreneuriat au masculin
n'a pas les mêmes problématiques et euh
et les mêmes questions quelles sont les
problématiques de l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin alors ben je pense que on se
pose beaucoup de questions euh avant de
passer à l'action je enfin en tout cas
moi c'est ce que j'ai constaté c'est que
euh on on cherche la perfection avant de
pouvoir se lancer alors que les hommes
spontanément en fait vont beaucoup plus
se lancer et après essuyer bah les les
les choses auxquelles ils n'auront pas
pensé et je pense que justement cet
entrepreneuriat au féminin est ralenti
par par cette façon de faire et vous
thérèe mayali pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez décidé de rejoindre l'association
Femmes des territoires j'avais besoin
effectivement comme comme un peu
Sandrine de sortir de ma solitude je
sortais du salariat j'ai enchaîné avec
ma version professionnelle où j'étais
dans une promotion assez nombreuse où on
fréquenta du monde régulièrement et puis
du jour au lendemain je me retrouve
toute seul à à créer et à faire autre
chose que mon activité c'estàd qu'on on
est sur énormément de palettes et on
sent très très seul et parfois démuni et
puis quand on a besoin de célébrer
certaines victoires ben aussi on est
seul et c'est et c'est ce réseau permet
vraiment ça c'est-à-dire que c'est un
réseau d'entraide et de partage
l'entraide à travers les ateliers et le
partage de ces doute mais aussi de ses
victoires et donc l'association elle
accepte n'importe quel projet
d'entreprise n'importe quelle femme qui
a un projet pour entreprendre ouiou il
y'y a pas de limite non non il y a pas
de limite il y a aussi l'objectif c'est
de faire développer ces entreprise donc
donc justement monter en compétence et
c'est vrai que entre la plateforme
digitale et les ateliers que l'on
organise dans chacune des antennes on
voit justement cette montée en
compétenence progressivement et euh bah
notre espoir c'est que les
entreprises
grossissent fructifi fluctu pardon et
euh et deviennent de plus en plus grand
quitent à embaucher aussi parce que
beaucoup de femmes sont souvent
solo-entrepreneurs et du coup
l'association elle regroupe combien de
femmes au total aujourd'hui environ on
est
environ 1200 adhérentes sur le plan
national euh et nous avant même d'avoir
officialisé notre propre antenne euh
nous sommes déjà 23 adér oui parce que
vous allez inaugurer une antenne à
rambouiller le 12 décembre donc il y
avait un besoin il y avait une demande
dans les Yvelines c'est concrètement un
besoin clair et et apparent c'est-à-dire
que en arrivant j'étais pas évelinoise à
l'origine je suis des haut scène j'ai
déménagé l'hiver dernier j'étais
rattachée à l'antenne de châtené malabri
et donc logiquement je m'étais dit je
vais me rattacher à l'antenne de
rambouiller ou des alentour tour et il
n'y avait rien effectivement comme l'a
dit très précisément Sandrine il y a
beaucoup de réseaux business euh dans le
coin vraiment beaucoup et il y a
quasiment aucun réseau d'entraide
officiel sous format associatif qui
apporte les mêmes bénéfices que femmes
des territoires donc c'est important euh
de créer cette antenne à rambouiller
comment ça fonctionne comment est-ce
qu'on entre dans la dans l'association
comment est-ce qu'on adhère alors c'est
une adhésion euh annuelle euh c'est 60 €
d'adhésion par an 30 % si vous êtes sous
minima sociaux et les deux premiers mois
sont gratuits et sans engagement une
fois que vous adhérz vous avez accès à
tout à la plateforme digitale avec les
coups de pouce les rencontres mais aussi
tous les ateliers disponibles sur la
plateforme digitale et puis l'accès à
l'ensemble des antennes sur le plan
national vous pouvez adhérer vous
rattacher à toutes les antennes de votre
choix et alors c'est quoi un coup de
pouce un coup de pouce
jepris un coup de pouce c'est c'est
demander justement une aide aux membres
aux adhérentes du réseau ça peut être
bah partager tester tester un nouveau
produit une nouvelle solution faire une
enquête auprès auprès d'un certain
public ça peut être tu as d'autres ça
peut être j'ai je dois faire un sondage
pour euh répondre à une question lié à
ma société je demande un coup de pouce
aux membres pour répondre à ce sondage
et amélioré tel point lié à mon
entreprise donc c'est assez ça peut être
très varié et c'est c'est très
intéressant de voir les le feedback des
adhérents qui sont toujours très
volontaires pour aider et porter les
autres ça peut être aussi participer
dans le cadre des formations de de
certaines personnes par exemple là j'ai
été sollicité pour aider une personne
qui est en train de se former à la
sophrologie elle avait besoin de deux
stagiaires qu'elle ne connaissait pas en
amont et donc qu'elle a fait un appel un
appel coup de pouce justement et je me
suis dit bah pourquoi pas découvrir déjà
la sophrologie et puis lui permettre à
elle de valider en fait sa formation
donc ça permet de se créer un réseau
très important oui vous avez parlé aussi
d'un mou qui permet de créer de suivre
des cours gratuits en ligne ce sont quel
genre de cours qu'on sont des ce sont
des ateliers en ligne vraiment avec des
modules très précis très détaillés
d'ailleurs Sandrine l'a suivi l'année
dernière la version de de l'année
dernière et ça permet de de de de se
faire accompagner à distance sur le
financement et le développement de son
de son activité et ça c'est complètement
gratuit oui tout à fait le mou je
finance mon projet donc est un mou qui
permet justement d'accompagner
d'aiguiller les personnes porteuses de
projets ou en essence d'entreprise ou
même cell qui se réorientent sur
d'autres solutions d'autres projets ça
permet de redescendre justement toutes
les thématiques de la création donc
aller chercher des financements mais
mais aussi savoir fixer son propre prix
à quel prix on va vendre telle et telle
prestation ça peut être aussi des idées
marketing des euh des techniques
marketing qui sont importantes justement
pour pour lancer en fait ce genre de
projet et c'est vrai que ce mou ce mou
est très intéressant parce qu'on peut le
faire à notre rythme euh et et aussi
partager au sein du mou avec d'autres
personnes qui sont dans les mêmes
chapitres donc il est vraiment bien bien
ficelé et euh même moi qui suis dans la
finance par exemple ça m' ça m'a apporté
beaucoup j'ai pu regarder en fait mon
entreprise avec des yeux de chefs
d'entreprise et non plus avec mon œil de
financière il y a aussi des rencontres
des événements qui sont organisés par
l'association quand est-ce que se
déroulera la prochaine à rambouiller
dans les ivelines il y a déjà une date
ou pas nous notre prochaine rencontre
officielle c'est la soirée
d'inauguration de notre
antenne le le mardi 12 décembre à 18h30
donc c'est notre prochaine notre
prochaine rencontre et puis dès lors on
va pouvoir lancer de manière officielle
aussi nos ateliers et nos rencontres à
travers des repas ou des afterwork et
bien merci beaucoup Sandrine tardityti
et Thérèse mayali d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions si vous êtes intéressés
vous retrouverez plus d'informations sur
le site
internetfemmeterritoires.fr l'adhésion
pour un an je le rappelle et de 60 €
gratuit les deux premiers mois et c'est
la fin de ce 78 merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous